hi everyone well I really wanted to take
some time out to make the case for amd's
radian RX 570 here now you might recall
that I looked at its Big Brother the RX
580 and made the case that although
perfectly decent it wasn't a game Cher
it was essentially a replacement for the
outgoing rx480 and you know what the RX
570 is basically the same thing for the
second tier product an overclocked RX
470 if you like but here's the thing I
love the 470 but it didn't really get a
huge amount of traction it was
overlooked for the most part my aim here
is to shine a spotlight on the 570 and
to show you what it can do yes I'll talk
benchmarks of course where there's a
great story to tell and yeah the
overclocking is okay too but more than
that I'll show practical uses for the
power on offer and yes this is fora
Horizon 3 running at 1080p at 60 frames
per second a visually impressive game
that is locked to 30 on Console but
first up let's take take a look at the
card AMD sent me for review it's the
assus STX model meaning beautifully
quiet operation with very nice build
quality power is delivered with a single
8 Pin input and to be honest nothing
more is needed while a back plate I owe
here consists of two dual link dvis
display port and HDMI 2.0 now this is a
more logical Arrangement than amd's
prior reference designs for Polaris
cards which killed off DVI support alog
together now this is a very
well-designed card over all and it's
factory overclocks out of the box giving
us a maximum boost clock of 1300 MHz
versus the reference 1244 the rest of
the card is at reference levels though
meaning 4 gigs of 7 GB per second ram
and 224 GB per second of bandwidth now
in theory this card should be a lot
slower than rx580 and even rx480 should
usefully beat it the clocks are low of
course at reference levels and memory
bandwidth drops by around 133% more than
that though the higher-end card's
compute unit count is reduced from 36 to
32 but here's the thing the actual real
life impact to performance by all of
these cutbacks is actually pretty
limited so let's do a bit of a three-way
here with the Asus rx570 here compared
to an MSI 580 and the reference 480 now
Crisis 3 is always great for stress
testing gpus and here we find the 580 is
about 11% faster than the 570 while the
reference 480 is only 2% ahead of the
new 570 in actual gameplay I reckon
you'll struggle to tell the difference
with the older Polaris card while the
main benefit in Real World gameplay with
a 580 will only really be felt when
performance is impacted hardest moving
over to the division in direct X12
there's a similar pattern 580 is around
12% faster here but the standard set by
the reference 480 sees a lead of only
1.3% in effect an RX 570 with just a 56
MHz Factory overclock is essentially
offering performance very very close to
the 480 and yeah if we factor in another
dx12 heavyweight ashes of the
singularity rx580 continues to be around
10% ahead but the 480s minuscule
performance Advantage drops to margin of
error stuff now let's be clear here I'm
not going to say that this assus card is
totally identical in performance terms
to a 480 because in many cases it isn't
but is quite close so let's roll out
rise at the Tomb Raider here the MSI 580
extends its lead to 15% here while the
reference 480 is around 5% faster than
our 570 and there are similar
differentials here with The Witcher 3
again the MSI version of the 580 it's
actually around 16% faster than our 570
and the reference 480 enjoys a 5% lead
in these titles there is an argument to
be said that there is distinct strata
separate ating the three products but
well let's talk overclocking the assus
stxs card I have here does indeed have a
56 MHz Factory OC in place but there's
enough Headroom left over to claw back
the lead that the reference rx480 enjoys
and then to surpass it now AMD has
limited our enjoyment of this somewhat
the RX 580 allows you to increase power
delivery by 50% and this is reduced to
just 25% on the 570 but it is enough to
get the job done I found total stability
with the core at 1390 MHz while the
memory could be overclocked to 8 GB per
second 2,000 MHz quad pumped here in MSI
afterburner and this equals the 256 GB
per second memory bandwidth of the 480
and the 580 now every card will vary of
course in terms of its overclocking
prowess but I think the overclocking
headro should be there to at least hit
480 levels of performance certainly with
our settings we get there and then some
now sometimes we just about claw our way
to rx480 levels of performance so with
Far Cry Primal here we're about 2.7%
faster than the 480 with the overclock
in place overhauling a 5% deficit
without the overclock in effect ashes of
the singularity sees the overclock 570
power ahead of the 480 by around 4.6%
which is nice while RIS of the 2 maer
also sees the overclock 570 inch ahead
of the 480 by around
2.4% yeah so it's not a revelatory
increase overall compared to the 580 but
in almost all cases it moves the 570
into a kind of midr between the 480 and
the 580 but remarkably this is only a 7
to 11% increase in performance across
our suite of games it's not a vast
overclocking margin but there's enough
here to achieve two purposes first of
all if you're tweaking settings for a
locked 60 frames per second that
additional overhead will keep you more
consistently at your target frame rate
and secondly yes there's actually a kind
of psychological Victory here knowing
that your second tier radian is a touch
faster than the flagship 480 that
launched just 10 months ago and let's
continue to talk about the value story
because price-wise the 570 fits
somewhere at a midpoint between the GTX
1060 3 gig version and the 1050 TI now
up against the cheaper Nvidia card it's
really no contest you're kind of looking
at extra 50% worth of performance but
generally the cutdown 1060 tends to inch
ahead in dx11 games while the 570 has an
advantage with dx12 I'm kind of thinking
that both versions of the GTX 1060
should get a price adjustment to tally
more closely with the 570 and 580 but
then again nvidia's cards seem to keep
selling like hot cakes regardless and
they've always been more expensive but
getting back to the rx480 comparisons
what I will say is that while your
compute power exceeds the 480 you're
still running with 4 gigs of RAM this
might cause issues with games that
utilize 4K textures like rise of the
Tomb Raider for example but dropping
from Ultra quality down to high isn't
exactly a hardship and you should always
be at least on par with console quality
assets with a 4 gig card and that's fine
for 1080p gaming generally but the
difference is that the RX 570 has the
horsepower to take you far beyond PS4
and Xbox one level of performance and
you don't need to surround your GPU with
the latest and greatest PC technology
either I've lashed up a system here
based on a 3.2 GHz i56500 with the rx570
you get something that consoles can't
deliver 1080p 60 gameplay let's go back
to fors of horizon 3 annoyingly this
game still needs a bit of work on PC in
terms of stability but when it works as
it should it looks Sensational we're
running at ultra settings here without
even overclocking the rx5 70 and we've
dialed back just two settings we've had
to disable msaa in favor of FXAA and
we've turned off the 4K textures so
we're on high there which is essentially
console equivalent 1080p 60 frames per
second nice so what about these glitches
then well I don't recall this happening
when I played the game at launch but I'm
pretty sure it's not the rx570 to blame
but that said the latest AMD driver
bizar has sent loading times on this
title shooting up to stratospheric
levels so who knows next up The Witcher
3 from CD project red alra settings No
Hair Works of course and to Iron Out
remaining drops below 60 frames per
second we drop grass density foliage
visibility range and detail level down
to high now we use this game for CPU and
GPU testing where super high frame rates
can expose GPU CPU and even memory
bandwidth limitations but using a 60
frames per second limit vsync
essentially you actually get to see how
well optimized this game is when you're
not trying to push your components to
Breaking Point and whether we're out in
the open world or taking a Gallop
through the taxing novigrad City stage
we're not breaking that 60 frames per
second lock here the RX 570 is
delivering now let's move on to another
console game that runs at 30 frames per
second that we can crank up to a full 60
with the rx570 that would be square nx's
rise of the Tomb Raider now I've teased
some 60 frames per second footage of
this earlier but how did we do it I mean
this is a notoriously hard game to run
at high frame rates well our plan here
was pretty simple we looked at the
console versions of the game to see how
they achieve their locked 30 frames per
second then brought those presets across
to PC so we're at 108p with high
settings as a base then we turn off
Sun's soft Shadows disable tessellation
and drop an isotropic filtering to 4X
yes this is one of the few PC games
where dropping AF is a must to achieving
solid frame rates quite possibly owing
to the inclusion of Parallax seclusion
mapping which can hit performance hard
in combination with high levels of AF
but here's the thing PS4 Pro does
actually have a 1080p performance mode
on similar settings and as you can see
it's nowhere near the lock 60 that we
have here on our PC now we've used the
geothermal Valley here as a stress test
area and pretty much if it works here it
should work well across the entire game
now let's take a look at Watchdogs 2
1080p here High settings texture
filtering and terrain quality set to
ultra and with screen space Reflections
disabled oh yeah and the horrendously
taxing San Francisco fog effect well
we've turned that off too now here we're
on par if not better in terms of visual
settings compared to the consoles and
running unlocked we can actually hit 60
to 80 frames per second so a 60 frames
per second lock is possible here on a
console game that targets half that
frame rate now we're using the overclock
here for additional stability
essentially allows us to remain locked
at 60 with resync enabled nice but
obviously there are a decent amount of
console games out there already
targeting 60 frames per second now here
you have two choices with the RX 570 now
with doom for example we can ramp up the
settings almost to the max here
everything by Nightmare shadowmap
quality specifically and still hit 1080p
60 frames per second without missing a
beat we're running with the Vulcan API
which the RX 570 support reports nicely
and we can actually move up to 1440p
resolution here and for the most part
we're still locked at 60 frames per
second with only the most minor drops
beneath and this is still better
performance overall than the console
versions dice's Battlefield 1 is a real
looker again 60 HZ game on Console as
well but our I5 rx570 PC setup allows
you to foro the dynamic resolution of
the console games we can lock up 1080p
effectively and yeah we can move beyond
the cons conso settings mixture that
kind of varies between medium and high
and just run everything at Ultra the I5
even has the CPU power required to
comfortably run 64 player multiplayer
battles and well that basically means
that it's a winwin all round and here's
another console game that runs at 60 HZ
Call of Duty infinite Warfare yeah this
one gets some heat but I really enjoyed
it actually and the optimization level
is generally superb so yes you can run
this one maxed out on the 570 at 1080p
with no problem whatsoever but with the
overclock in place you can actually use
the resolution scaler at 140% for super
sampling so internally we're kind of
rendering at 2688 by 1512 before down
sampling to 1080p you get the odd frame
rate drop in cutcenes but gameplay is
solid so yeah this is another game that
should run just fine at 1440p based on
these tests so what's the takeaway here
well PS4 Xbox One are effectively PCS in
a box and the specs of those consoles
helps to define the Baseline of a great
experience on most multiplatform games
but the CPU in those boxes a week and
the gpus are getting on now the rx570
essentially offers you at least two
times the real world rendering power of
those machines and far more than that in
terms of your notional teror flops pair
the RX 570 with a decentish modern i5
and your effectively have a PC that
offers the experience that the likes of
project Scorpio and PS4 Pro have side
stepped so yeah 4K is pretty much off
the table but there's a highly
worthwhile alternative 1080p Gameplay at
60 frames per second if there's one
weakness with the 570 well I kind of
think it needs to be £ 150 $150 GPU to
really make an impact right now it's
just a bit too expensive to the point
where getting a decent Factory
overclocked rx470 might actually be the
better and certainly the cheaper bet but
that's where I'm going to leave it for
now I hope you found this video useful I
certainly had fun putting it together so
please like subscribe follow us on
Twitter and consider supporting the
digital Foundry patreon if you value
what we do but for me for now thanks for
watching